is free after 40 years in an Israeli
prison friends and family gathered in
ARA to welcome him home Eunice was the
longest held Palestinian prisoner he and
his cousin Kareem were arrested in 1983
and convicted of murdering an Israeli
soldier Kareem was released two weeks
ago
the first thing Eunice did was a visit
to his father's grave he died 12 years
ago
I always hoped when I was free to see my
homeland liberated Eunice was born in
ahara in 1958 just 10 years after the
nakeda when hundreds of thousands of
Palestinians either fled over forced
from the homes to make way for Jewish
settlers when Israel was founded in 1948
his parents chose to stay and later
became Palestinian citizens of Israel
with that Eunice says she can't believe
she lived to see her son a free man how
do you feel like I just needed his hug
this is the best feeling ever
the celebrations were quite Palestinians
are not allowed to have loud parties or
even fly the national flag by order of
the new Israeli security minister
etymar bengiver
Eunice is viewed here as a symbol of
Palestinian resistance to the Israeli
occupation
he was telling reporters and family
members and friends and peace activists
here that despite the fact that he was
freed he felt sorrow for thousands of
Palestinian prisoners who are still an
Israeli prisons
Israel